اهلا ومرحبا بكم موقف الصين اتجاه عدناك
اوكرانيا دائما ومستمر وواضح
واليوم في الصباح الاعلان الصين
مبادرات ذاتي 12 نقاط
للدفع لحل السياسي للازمه في اوكرانيا
مثلا
احترام سياده كل الدول ونبدا فكره الحرب
البارده وكذلك وفي اطلاق النار فورا
للمحادثات
وتفاوض للسلام وحل اللازمه الانسانيه
وكذلك حمايه المدنيين والاسرار
لا تعدوا هذه
ربما مبادئ عامه لم تدخل الصين في بيانها
الى التفاصيل مثلا كيف
عن مصير مثلا مناطق احتلتها روسيا
كشبه جزيره القرم مثلا
على الاقل يعني يجب البدء المفاوضات
لتتناول هذه
الاجراءات المسائل المموسه
حاليا هو وقت سيدراك النهار وبدل
المفاوضات ففي
ان هذه الحرب لا يجب ان تستمر ولانه
استمرت يعني
سيزيد المعاناه الشعب الاوكراني وكذلك
الشعوب في الدول الاوروبيه فلذلك اولا
المفاوضات وثم
رغم هناك يعني هذا الامر صعب ولكن اصعب
يبقى كلما كان يجب اعطاء الفرصه
هناك عده اطراف على راسها الولايات
المتحده لا تثق في هذه النوايا الصينيه هي
بالعكس تقول ان
الصين ربما تستعد لمساعده وامداد
روسيا
بالاسلحه كيف ترد بكين على يعني عظام
الثقه هذه في الموقف هذا في الموقف الصيني
بخصوص هذا تاكدت سيمراره تكرارا انها لن
تقدم اي اسلحه لاي طرف في هذا النزاع وليس
مثل الولايات المتحده يعني التقديم
باستمرار
الاوكراني من اجل القتال الصين يعني لا
تريد تريد الوقت القتال والحرب فورا وكذلك
بادل المفاوضات فلذلك تقدم اي اسلحه يعني
لان هذه الاسلحه ايضا ستزيد معاناه
المدنيين
ويعني
تقديم الاسلحه هو تجاهلا لامن السلام
لامني حياتي المواطنين باوكرانيا لذلك
موقفها حياديه ودائما تقف على جانب حوار
والسلام نعم شكرا لك سيد الصحفي من في
وكاله الصين للاعلام شكرا لك على حضورك
معنا